what up space fam goes in here from
anime out / to discuss the latest
chapter of the board tol manga and the
return of one of the best characters in
anime in my all southern Hokage and
their powers explained video link in the
description
I asked if you guys want to see some
boruto content and many of you did if
you do want to keep seeing board torch
out to reviews then show berto some love
by smashing that like button if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future Naruto and boruto videos
I'll have boats for future Naruto videos
on Instagram at anime uproar so feel
free to follow us there if you want to
help decide what videos I make in the
future
just look up anime helper on Instagram
or click the link in the description
keep in mind there will of course be
manga spoilers here since we are
discussing the latest chapter of
Bordeaux after all so I've just caught
up with boruto and I gotta say I like it
a lot in manga form there are so many
similarities with Naruto that I can't
really see Naruto fans not liking it
however I'm specifically talking about
the manga since I did start watching the
board to animate and kept stopping
because of the fillers in contrast the
manga is a page-turner and I caught up
to in like two days and I wasn't really
even trying to catch up that quickly
I just kept wanting to see what happens
next but anyways chapter 47 is called
predestined fate and that's an
interesting title because it is a
recurring idea in Naruto whether or not
people can change their fate in the
beginning nor to a sort of portrayed as
an underdog who has to change his fate
but then we discovered that he's the son
of Hokage holder of the strongest
jinchuriki and pretty much fated to be
the chosen one so that kind of raises
questions about whether he changed fate
or whether he just fulfilled his destiny
Neji was another guy who was associated
with possibly being able to escape his
fate but then he ended up doing when he
was arguably destined to do which was to
protect the main branch of the Hyuga
clan he sacrificed his life for Hinata
and the man she loved
so the Naruto series has sort of a weird
relationship with destiny and fate so
I'm especially interested in seeing how
the boruto series will complement or
even contradict the Naruto series in
this regard this chapter of boruto
starts with the battle between Koji
Kasia and Isshiki continuing we get an
interesting twist where coach
summons real flames rather than chakra
flames so Yogi's karma cannot absorb
them
these subtle intricacies and
distinctions when it comes to fights are
something I really like about both
Naruto series and although Isshiki looks
in trouble he manages to just use his
shrinking powers to shrink the flames
we're told that he can shrink himself
and other nonliving things and return
them back to normal size
nothing super original but it's
interesting to see how well it is used
by this skilled villain we're reminded
that Koji and the scientists a model
specifically decide to attack now
because a shiki's vessel geon's body has
reached its limit
after the fight against naruto and
sasuke because of the lack of recovery
time Jigen z' body can't keep shrinking
the eternally burning flames of the
flaming mountains and these ever burning
flames are another cool detail about the
Naruto world Koji is just chillin like a
boss watching Jigen burn Sasuke points
out that as long as the Akatsuki have
karma they'll keep being resurrected so
Naruto shouldn't assume it's over the
naruto and sasuke dynamic continues
umberto and that's something I really
appreciate we also see that dynamic
reflected in Berto and Kalki's
relationship as well even though in the
beginning board two initially said that
this series would be his story not
Naruto's Naruto has definitely had a
huge presence in this series so far in
Sasuke 2 which is another reason I've
really enjoyed it Sasuke then reminds us
that if ishiki was to reincarnate in
cahuachi he would be unstoppable
and it seems initially like this is what
the scientists Amato is planning people
were react including cocky and it
emphasizes how horrible a model is at
delivering the right information at the
right time but maybe he just likes
messing with everybody after Sasuke
checks kawaki Amano calmly continues to
explain what's going on he definitely
gets cool points for how little fazed he
gets by everything he explains that
Yoshiki once dead will automatically be
reincarnated into one of his vessels
since Kalki is not ready he'll be
reincarnated into jjigae and keep in
mind vessels don't have to be living
bodies they can be corpses as a shiki's
reincarnation into his new vessel takes
place all eyes are on ecology as a motto
expects to observe
thing happening to him surprisingly
after quite a show we see that colic he
no longer has a karma diamond on his
palm at all it disappears
we then see the reincarnated yaki and
his power is much greater than it just
was pre reincarnation clergy observes
the tremendous power and notices all the
eternal flames shrink in an instant a
motto goes on to explain that kawaki
lost his mark because when a
reincarnation takes place all other
karma are erased no matter how many
vessels exist again he could have
explained this sooner but his way
definitely makes for a more interesting
chapter with more twists and turns and
now that there are no more vessels that
is finally possible to kill an immortal
or tootski for good we see you shaky
looking pretty dangerous and his design
is definitely cool in a weird alien way
this is what core G has been waiting for
but his toad that is sending the live
feed gets done in and our dudes lose the
ability to follow what's happening but a
motto says the Koji succeeded his
function or destiny which was to drag
Isshiki out of jjigae so he can be
killed
Amado explains that the plan was not for
Koji to make it since a Shiki isn't that
easy to beat Naruto is upset by this and
wants to know whether Koji knew that
this battle was a one-way ticket to the
afterlife
Naruto can't figure out why exactly so
concerned about Koji and that's some
more for shouting for the craziest
Bertil twist that is about to be
revealed
we jump to Koji Nishiki and the idea of
destiny comes up
Yoshiki says that all people and genes
have a predestined fate again it's the
bad guy who's spouting off this
philosophy then Yoshiki mentions a man
who bore a mighty faith a star of change
and clergies mask comes off we see an
image of Jiraiya from behind and Isshiki
says that a motto wanted to cling to
that man's mighty fate to the miniscule
possibility of change and then we see
caution koji with no mask and we learned
that he is in fact a clone of Jiraiya
Yoshiki says that Koji dying here was
also predestined by his genes and that
is the end of this insanely epic chapter
I love to see Jiraiya backing away in
the series because he was arguably my
favorite Naruto character and I like the
way they did it - there were so many
clues and it definitely wasn't pulled
out of nowhere
we learned that Mitsuki was a clone of
Orochimaru which put the idea of clones
out there then there's all those clues
that core ginger I were connected
including the toads including the fact
that he could enter Konoha undetected
including Naruto recognizing him and his
fighting style and so on it was well
foreshadowed and in my view this is a
very satisfactory way to bring back one
of my favorite characters into the story
so props Roberto series for that I
really hope we don't just see Koji die
next chapter as is being suggested here
if that were to happen again that would
reaffirm that can't change destiny stuff
that the bad guys talking about is
pretty real in the Naruto world I'd sort
of be upset if I just had to watch
Jiraiya sacrifice himself all over again
so I'm really really hoping there's
gonna be more to it and that he somehow
gets out of there alive but we shall see
maybe this series just enjoys pulling at
the heartstrings of every Jiraiya fanboy
one thing's for sure now that Koji has
been revealed to be dry as clone he
better have an epic death worthy of
Jiraiya if he has to die and that's it
for my first ever chat review of boruto
let me know if you like boruto if you
like where the manga is right now and
what you think will happen in the next
few chapters if you enjoyed this board
tour video I want to keep them coming be
sure to smash that like button until
it's blue and share this video with
fellow boruto fans if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and this is crucial
ring that notification bell or you will
miss future Naruto and boruto videos
I'll have votes for future Naruto videos
on Instagram and anime uproar so feel
free to follow us there if you want to
help decide what videos I make in the
future just look up and me out drawer on
Instagram or click the link in the
description I gotta say I am so into
this series right now it's so nostalgic
for the Naruto fanboy in me and it's
definitely a page-turner
lastly the YouTube ad rates have
significantly dropped recently so the
help and support we're getting from our
anime upper patrons is now more
important than ever a very special thank
you goes out to our patrons over on
patreon who help us survive these
YouTube issues and well
videos like this one possible first and
foremost I want to thank the legend
acknowledged by Laurent we go himself
every day and the one tear patrons the
ones who stand atop all clients Steven
Ingrid ah a Lola nitendo world stealers
acquire respect but they have a Jonathan
King Dessie deep Brandon of Isles Papa
Smurf the school bus King riser emperor
otaku Richie Martinez and Thomas Jones
and our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson Kings I'll just Anatole
kozloski angel Cruz cricket XP Joel
Stanton very Gucci Alicia actor
Jessica Calif on Kinoko me and water
Bonnie parks OD are 12 or to end day or
Tian Wong cynical crack and fungus 77
and Dudley Saints thank you all so much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to
patreon.com/scishow OPFOR and becoming a
patron today for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get name featured in
future videos alongside these amazing
people right here
and you'll even get access to a private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course dank memes
so check out Pete chong kham / anime
I'll put a link in the description if
you're interested you can also now join
YouTube channel and support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same great benefits thanks again and
until next time see us space cowboys
[Music]